okay for people joining this meeting
this is orphan language design
review this is part of our incremental
language development
uh sequence and looks like first off we
are talking about a very good new idea
um that doesn't yet have a good name
okay
so
we've got some
should i shall i pull up the
yeah ian started putting together a ref
page under ref supplied um there's a
couple of other topics here
uh we also have tom sherlock here to
talk about autocomplete since that was
something you brought up
okay you can attack these in whatever
order
piques your interest but uh i thought
they're referencing well i think i think
first of all
so as you started have you started an
implementation of this thing
we haven't really because there's a lot
of tendrils
you know it
we could potentially look at an
implementation in a top level discrete
function but i don't know
whether there's a framework that says we
can have a single implementation of
applied and
functions like map and replace and
select can just tie into it or if
they're going to be a bunch of function
specific hooks or
we could fake it out effectively with
with up values as a prototype yeah
that's what i think we should try to do
because i think we're going to see some
issues though
um and i did implement this for tree map
have a branch open for that
okay
and how does it feel
it seems to work well
yeah
i mean you're happy with it
yeah i want to add that to
also like tree fold and also all of the
tree visualization options
and i think it's going to be very useful
in all of those cases
okay
so
how how much are we done
okay has somebody looked through what
other functions can take this
yes this is the initial list that i put
together every symbol you see here in
the notes
okay
so these are mostly
functional programming
operations um
do we think there's anything
uh
outside of the domains you've picked up
there where
we're just not thinking but it should be
there
anything like with entities or something
like that
so i think
this could be in almost any domain
[Music]
uh i think images
i know that i understand but i'm trying
to get a design
don't image measurements have some weird
thing that's a bit like this
component measurement has it
what is it then
it's the selection function
what does that mean
um so basically the
there are two ways i mean i just think
the only similar thing is the
association syntax you see that for
example the second example
has a
component measurement elongation count
so of course that knows that it has to
compute count as well
right but so this is something but not
return property
right so this is something where it is
i mean i can imagine for example in in
graphs
i think we maybe talked about this
before
where you know vertex shape function
this is clearly a useful thing
am i making sense
um
because right now i mean so here's
another place where it's useful is um
in the graphics functions where we are
saying you know like a color function
for example okay so let's look at those
two cases so i claim
we should be looking at
cases where
things implicitly take
multiple
function arguments okay so this is a
case where
here
see this this statement there
this thing here
that's a case where surely we should be
able to do it like this with named
arguments there
does that make sense to people like
center vertex and dimensions
yeah for example
or center name
um
well
one of the problems there is that
that we faced at least with the
component measurement
and we kind of
skipped that when
when we
was in conflict with the existing syntax
it was at the
this type of function takes a sequence
of arguments while the
the other thing requires uh
an association as a as the first
argument
so i actually want to to do something
magical by
passing it around no no no no no that's
the whole idea there's two forms of
supplied for that reason
oh okay okay
um
right but so clearly something of this
generality would have to be
implemented one function at a time right
there's no way this can be a framework
yep i agree i mean the the core
thing will be set up but okay i would
like a framework or at least just a tool
to do the lexical scanning
of course so that
each developer doesn't worry about so so
okay so we've got these kinds of
functions
um the other one i would like to point
to is things like color function
which again has this issue
that you know we can see in that i mean
there look look at all these things
i mean it's not
this is somewhat a luxury item here but
you know having the possibility of these
things being named seems highly useful
to me
um
and if we allow those names we can
potentially bring in
yet different attributes
that we were not able to make use of
here because we didn't want seven
arguments
am i making sense
so for example like the tree element
shape function option i think
i i would
think the simplest thing is it just
takes the data by default and then you
can
bring in things like position and
all the extra things if you
as opposed to vertex shape function
or
it's the three that vertex shape
function had in mind initially
okay
what's the what what's the story here
okay so
this thing here
i'm trying to understand this
this says
we're the first argument used
to define the things you're pulling in
so the two argument form
you give a sequence of arguments
the one argument form you give an
association
the two argument form
oh really okay okay that's what we want
to do we don't want to have this two
argument form simply define what
elements there will be in the
association we think that's redundant
and also the second the two argument
form can use symbols that have
definitions and the one argument form
can only work with pure functions
sure
oh i see what you're saying i see what
you're saying you're saying but i mean
the two argument form could simply be a
pruning of the association you know
don't bother to look up
well so that's the example below you see
um like if you map indexed a pure
function you're going to be putting a
pure function in
rather than wrapping the thing in f
and in the one argument form it's
even different because you would also
need to be putting associations in
i'm sorry i'm totally confused look at
the three map the so map indexed f
of hold of one plus one two plus two
that's strictly just putting f's into
the expression
yes you can't
accomplish that with a pure function in
the first argument
what about the pure function f of hash
one comma hash two
no look that's what you get you have
that pure function around the arguments
instead of f
what my point is
my point is just that the pure function
is not the same as the f it's just that
observation
literally putting a pure function in
you're not literally putting an f in
yeah yeah yeah
until you're asking should we be putting
in this case
and it may or may not do what you want
well i don't understand
what what what's the objection here
i mean
of course this is true if you have a
hold there it will take whatever you put
here and it will wrap that around it and
in this case it won't evaluate we know
that
his point is that you could
using
uh
right
that that map supplied
of whatever right it's literally giving
you
uh
right you'd literally end up with
uh you know if this were actually
implemented
right you would actually end up with the
index raised
to
the expression
as opposed to
right
you know what you can't do with the pure
function form
which is required by the one argument
form that's applied
so it's just a limitation of pure
functions that
i'm sorry i'm totally there
and i'm just saying
what's the issue is that when you hold
it it doesn't evaluate or what but
what's the issue the point is that map
is not and it does not evaluate the
function it's applying it's just
inserting
indeed things
so i'm saying so what's the point here
is this evaluation my point is that you
won't be able to get
slash index to the slot expression
unless you use the two argument form
my point is how is this different
indexed
how is this different from normal map
index
well i'm understanding
is what i'm saying
when it does evaluate the argument form
of supply does what map index does the
one argument form does not it's right
but when it if it ever does evaluate
it'll give the exact same result right
you can't make the assumption that you
want it to ever evaluate like that
right but i'm just saying that you know
yeah i mean if you put it in a hole
you're going to get some different
expression because you wrote a different
function in but if you ever release the
hold it's going to evaluate to the same
thing won't it
but my point is why are you
assuming that you will release the hold
later no no no no but but this i mean
why is it why why is this not done by by
using i mean i know map doesn't run i
function on its thing
and actually do this but why why do we
want to actually construct this
association
why don't we run i function on it with
um
i would think so
and i mean is there anything special
about supply that requires this bizarre
thing that just doesn't make sense
well actually i mean that's what you're
calling the bizarre thing rob
the fact that it doesn't substitute the
elements that you a that you're creating
an association
and b that it's it's all this this held
thing
instead of running
you know the the the lexical
substitution i mean the substitution can
be done without evaluating
right and and my point is only the two
argument form of supplied can do that
the one argument form cannot because
it's limited to pure functions
i mean this is this is one of the things
that we talked about early on as well
which which is that for the sake of of
optimization it kind of it kind of
better not have to construct the
association in the one argument form i
mean conceptually that's what it's doing
but in practice it would be nice if it's
yeah in practice that the thing to do is
to create
create a hash table which is the
the hashmap thing and this thing and
then replace the values
you know with those keys with the the
associated things as they come up rather
than create an association every single
time you're evaluating a function the
wrong idea that's that's that's nuts
yeah
so you would fill the slots and then
strip off the outer function wrapper but
not do an evaluation
i think so
yeah yeah i would fill that i would i
would fill those slots based on some
kind of a hash table look up it doesn't
have to be an association lookup
it just needs to be a hash table lookup
to be efficient
out of curiosity also what happens if
you call
let me think if there's a way of getting
this to happen like what happens if if
you call map over like i don't know a
hold of associations and you use
you know hash the hash key syntax does
it does it fill them in or does it stay
unevaluated
it stays unevaluated yeah right which i
guess makes sense with that setup i'm
just wondering if there's a setup where
you could somehow get them to fill
oh that there are i mean it's like it's
like using you know
numbered slots within functions that
themselves have numbered slots there's
you know some scoping that's done but
but
you know you're not it's not always
guaranteed to be exactly what you expect
okay
um
all right so
what we're proposing here is
that
go ahead
right so what what is the one argument
formed one argument form is
a pure function
which is will be
the main point about it is it is
lexically scanned
for keys
okay
and it applies to association
conceptually applies to an association
okay well the other the other form is
definitely those
do those keys have to be in the list
that's shown in the the ref page
or could they be any random keys they
cannot be random keys okay they are
brought in from the environment and only
certain things are known in that
environment yeah
yeah okay i mean arguably
we should have a key
that is the list of keys that can be
brought in
see what i'm saying happening just say
keys of hash i mean i guess that's less
efficient but
i mean this is a discovery thing right
well i'm just saying hash keys
should be the list of the strings that
are the names of the keys
keys of hash would do the same thing
won't it
yes that's correct yeah yes so we'd have
to scan for that right
well i don't know if we have to scan for
i mean that's kind of i would argue
that's a pretty niche discovery thing
that yeah you can have points i
understand that but i'm saying in the
lexical scanner
that's looking lexically at this pure
function if it sees a naked hash that's
what it will do with it yes absolutely
if it sees a naked hash then it does
have to actually construct the
association
yeah yeah exactly
okay
so
let me understand the two argument form
here
so the two argument form
is effectively like a it is it is
pulling things into a function
and it's then going to just supply these
as the hash one hash two of this pure
function here correct
it's just going to they will going to
whatever whatever expression is there
with the elements corresponding to what
you specify
it's just a wrap thing right so if
that's f
that thing is f
that will put it on to hash index
whatever hash index whatever the value
would have been for hash index and yes
okay
that sounds good to me now
and if it's not a list then it's an
additional argument
i'm sorry what do you mean if it's not a
list
look at the second bullet point
where you say supply of just the string
index
oh right
yeah yeah right that's nice so it'll
it'll
you know in map the default is the one
argument that is the expression and so
you give the index as an additional
argument at the end
but if it's something that has already
multiple arguments
like bold the f takes two arguments so
it would be giving it as a third
argument what should this thing be
called let's have one one little poke at
that right now if we can't figure it out
right now we will keep going
and um
uh you know well i can tell you what it
should not be called and that's
associated
right
um
[Music]
uh
[Music]
explain why
right because first of all it
uh
right first of all it's making a link to
association which
right we're
not going to sort of literally be
constructing
all right okay you might be you might be
right okay can somebody tell me avery do
you know where i put the the notes on
the stuff
it's in the multi-computation folder
sw008
thanks
another problem is that it sort of adds
to that we then have association
associated
and like associates
my brilliant idea is dying on the vine
yeah
so it goes
all right
right i argued for using
which uh you know christopher has the
programmer's objection to that
you know that's sort of like a a pound a
pound include type in multiple
programming languages
which i understand i'm not sure i agree
with but i understand that concern
well having never seen this before
um
i was able to get the idea of what it
was from supplied without
you know too much mental aerobics
yeah
it's a little bit the wrong type of it
will be more like supplying
although supplied
yeah
i mean to me what it implies is the idea
they're coming from sort of the
traversal environment
basically
and
and
they're supplied by are supplied by the
traversal environment which is nice
umbilicaled
but you know we've got these two
different forms one of which
i think
the more obscure case
it's just not the right type of you know
it's just rather weird i mean we've got
these two cases we've got a case where
it gives the argument explicitly
i mean if that case said let's look at
our cases here we've got
this thing
here and by the way whatever happened to
the discussion about this
in rules
did we
understand that also
what was what was somebody suggested
like rule slot
no i'm sorry well no this this is you
want for for replace all you want on the
right hand side to be able to ask where
the replacement was made
yes that's what we're talking about and
and i think each time we came to this
i don't know we sort of
i think
each proposal we had was sort of
troubled and i think it's a bit of
yeah
well but it's very useful thing don't
you think
potentially and part of the problem is
just that the right hand side of a rule
in the case of something like replace is
a pattern not a function
and these are really not the same thing
but i mean that function the slash
i mean by the way you can already do
some amount of that
well
no okay i guess no i was gonna say you
could do some amount of that just with
pattern matching but but not if not at
arbitrary depth
right but i mean so what is it that we
want here we want something where we can
say
you know blah slash dot
and then we want to say
you know f of x blank
for example semicolon
only if this thing
you know let's say
i'm writing down something rough you
know hash depth is less than five
maybe
right and that make i mean
that theoretically
could be supplied right because
the well how would it work we'd say we'd
say no but this wouldn't take a function
usually i mean we could say something
like right i guess it's an expression
so yeah
and well okay i mean
maybe another example would this work as
well would be something like you know x
slash dot f of x
uh you know colon greater than
you know g of
the position at which this replacement
was done
yeah
right right what we need is a thing is a
different kind of function here
that basically fills in okay what we
need
this thing i don't think this is
replaced because you need an alternative
to slot
why i i think you need slaughters for
functions
no no it's like a slot for pattern
matching
oh i see what you're saying
well okay i mean this is the fundamental
problem is that it's just like you know
we have all these function versus pat
you know cases versus select you know
this is like we have supplied which is
for select and we're trying to use it in
cases right well what happens if you
um and i mean either
why isn't this a preprocessor why
doesn't it because this is a
this isn't going to change this is for
any given application of this rule
this is a
am i writer is that not true i was
thinking oh gosh no because there might
be one of your motivations we use slot
outside of function no
no i'm i'm i'm looking to have a thing
where
this rule
before slash dot
even picks up and looks at this rule
it has
it is resolved
do you know what i'm saying
yeah in fact you could have a symbol i
mean we could just have
a magic symbol that's called like you
know i don't know pattern matching
context not that name but pattern
matching context and you would just
write g of pattern matching context of
quotes depth or something like that yeah
right
and that just gets replaced along with
all the bound
you know variables are you just trying
to control where the rule gets applied
or also no
it's actually trying to give that value
right so i i you know i'm not sure
i'm not sure this is actually a good
idea but i was going to suggest maybe
if we had a if we used supplied here
then it should probably be the second
right the head of the second argument so
it should wrap the entire rule
i'm still not sure that solves our
problem but
here like this
um
yes
i'm not sure it's a good idea because i
think that that's a
that's using a rule as something to be
applied to things that is this isn't
so i'm i'm going to ask the question
if we had a decent name for this and it
wasn't as insane as that
is this a reasonable thing to try to do
is this semantically correct
that this is something just that is seen
by the pattern matcher
and whenever it sees one of those
it's not seen it's it's replaced i mean
i think what it would be is that any
time you know as in in a condition or on
the right-hand side of a rule or in any
of these cases where basically it's
taking bound pattern variables and
replacing them it would also replace
this
right so you're saying in a case like
this where we're saying that it can say
and p e
depth
you know less than five
now
and i would argue that any time at any
time you're in a context like in a
condition or the right-hand side of a
rule and you're replacing pattern
variables you probably have all the
information you need to replace these as
well
yeah i'm sure that's true
i mean there are even things meta things
that one can imagine
that says things like you know oops that
says
things like um you know
number of matched
number matched so far
or you know blanks matched so far
that's a little scarier but yeah
i
i mean theoretically yes given the
structure of the pattern matching code
i'm not sure that's actually
a thing you can answer an answer
yeah okay well fair enough
i mean what happens what i see
is that if you i mean one one another
issue i see is i mean presumably you're
thinking this in context of say replace
all or cases or something but what if
somebody defines a down value with this
you know what what's the actual level
at which a down value fires let's say
it's inside another down value
yeah we're presumably the keys that you
can supply this are
you know they're not they're not
universal for all patterns it depends on
what function this pattern is right so
that's that's what i'd find a bit a bit
problematic because
yeah yeah what what would it actually
return it would say missing not
available probably
but that then requires a whole confirm
structure around it and so on right but
realize down values
when when you enter down values and you
look at the down values those are just
given as rules right
yeah but but the fact is you might
you're passing through a filter there of
don't use this if you're making a down
value definition
right do we have any other any other
pattern
constructs that only work in some
patterns but not all
i mean are there any things like oh you
can you can't you know in these patterns
in this context you can't bind names to
them or something there are
there are corner cases well two things
i've mentioned
one is something that was in version .9
that never made it to version 1.0 which
was the cut these patterns that you know
return unevaluated if you get to this
state return unevaluated
so i'm saying in other words a
return self type thing we had a couple
of mechanisms with that and we really
should re-look at those again sometime
but those
work only and down value stuff they
don't really work in
they because in an ordinary slash dot
you know replace all situation all it
says is oh i don't match sorry and it
just goes on it's in the down value case
that you can have done a whole bunch of
computation and then it says
uh
i guess
well it could happen in slashdot as well
so in other words it's a thing where
you know given the right-hand side the
right-hand side makes the decision that
actually it didn't match
see what i'm saying so it's not enough
you
did this this didn't make it in though
right it didn't make it in right it's
it's been it's been languishing for a
third of a century right but i guess the
question is whether there's any
precedence for having something which is
you know only works in cases but not in
you know match queue or something so
blank works in
like expression patterns and string
patterns but string patterns have
different kinds of constructs
that don't work for expression patterns
yeah that's sort of an analogy yeah
those are i would argue those are just
totally different things though but yeah
okay but the question here is
i don't even know that all keys
for this pattern
environment thing would not work in down
values
we're not even down values i mean
there's just even stuff like you know
match queue i mean match i guess it can
say depth is one or something or zero or
i don't know i mean i'm just guessing
that there are keys that
you know
maybe we need to actually list out what
keys you want but i'm i bet that they're
things that you'd have in cases that you
won't even match okay the basic point
here is
you know
this
is relevant
uh for you know
uh recursive borrowing functions
like slash dot
it's not relevant even for replace
is it
well you might you might be able to have
i mean there might be some interesting
things they might be able to ask it for
an association of all the bound
variables oh yeah or something like that
places
replacing that reversal of an expression
so i think it also applies there well
but okay but then then in terms of the
bound variable lists and so on that
would work in down values too
sure
i mean that is a useful thing so i mean
yes so so one key would be
something like um
bound variable rules or something
or it wouldn't it's an association isn't
it
yeah okay
well we sometimes call that whatever
um
okay but but yeah i mean that seems like
an interesting thing right there which
we've never had is what matched
um
look i like the idea of having this just
be some magic symbol
that is
that is simply filled in
either from the environment or from the
pattern
instance
instancing
and if you ask for depth
and you're doing cases for example
well
it can it is looking you know that is
the thing which is looking outward
as it is in most most of the map cases
map situation
with with whatever supplied is called
there
so yes so
now here's a question
why is this construct
not the way that we do things for map as
well
in other words why not have this
a thing
that in map
evaluates you know a magic
token
that has the same feature
that it
does do you see what i'm saying i mean
it's a little bit weird in terms of
scope but you could do the same thing
i mean conceptually hash is basically
that magic token
it's a weird way to think about it yes
with the things we're talking about with
supplied i think this needs some kind of
syntax
like slot does
well
is compared with like supplied where you
do have the two arguments
or even not like
having a symbol around the keys instead
of
just like slot expression
hold on a second if are you saying that
the fact that we are
i mean if if we had
a funky symbol for this okay
then we could presumably over here
instead of doing this we could actually
get away with this
and this will be our funky whatever it
is
right and basically the implementation i
mean honestly the implementation for for
you know on the side of map or something
would probably be much simpler because
it basically just has to you know
lexically replace
you know all the whatever this funky
symbol is in a similar way now function
replaces hashes but obviously it
wouldn't be with function
and then it you know calls the function
right
right but the thing would have to be
literally present right it's
you couldn't do something like
well i guess you you can't
you couldn't do something
so the question what you're asking
italia is
if a function called from the function
you say map of f comma whatever
and now
i think this is very well badly defined
anyway that somewhere inside the body of
f
it now reaches out and says oh that map
that i was called from
use the index from that map that i was
called from
i claim that's not very well defined
because by the time you're a couple of
levels down you have no idea which map
it was that you thought you were called
from
yeah i mean also i would argue it's it's
it would be bad programming practice
just because it's kind of like
when you write a function it should be
able to work outside of the context of
this one particular map
right but i guess my claim is what if i
have my function f and i want it
am i going to write
f of funky symbol of depth
or am i going to write f funky symbol of
depth
ampersand no just funky symbol of depth
if you want the amazon stuff
you would be able to all right well then
how how how
you know
i mean i guess it's different that would
have to be on the right
so then we have to scan every single
expression that's given lexilly scan for
funky symbol
that you know
well everything will
we have efficient ways to do that i
don't think we should freak out about
that immediately
but semantically what this is doing is
it's saying
this is a thing
that
it's like a with map is effectively
putting in a width there
that is replacing the funky symbol
with the actual value based on the
current environment of the map
correct
yeah i think so i i
is it is it the case that this funky
symbol can
either be used in the body of a pure
function or on the right hand side of a
set or set delayed
computer when you're asking
is it the same function like symbols
we're talking about for you to have f of
funky symbol in the map unless you're
doing a pure function there
well there's there's a rare case if you
have some operator form or something
yeah well you can say that explicitly
you just say f of you know whatever this
thing is hash question mark index and
that's it
and you're saying map that and and that
happens to be the um you know that would
otherwise be a map indexed of two sub
one
maybe maybe for now don't you the hash
question mark syntax is both very weird
and i think it's also confusing because
there's a hash in it
when there's no ampersand
that point
okay let me just
what am i saving this to
this is an ilp
okay what just just for my
you know
what could we conceivably use for this
so what would that do
the f of
funky symbol index
it would just replace it would just put
in okay do you want me to write it would
map over the function to try yeah do do
mapping a different expression over each
part all it is is this
wait uh no
no no no that would not be the last
there's no ampersand of of hash of hash
one
after the but before the ampersand just
do open bracket hash one
there you go yes that's what it would do
so basically it's just
a lot weirder than what we were talking
about with patterns where you're putting
something on the right-hand side of a
rule
it's like you're basically working
really well and your mapping is changing
i mean what this basically is again i'm
not sure this is a good idea but
basically what this is it's just
you know in the same way that you can
have a pure function and it will you
know replace all the the slots or
something this is just
on the you know the the the first
argument of the map is sort of treated
as a not a pure function but a
something
and it will replace all of these and
then it will do the you know if you
happen to give it a pure function then
it will do all the replacements of the
slots
so it's kind of like environment
function
it's a two-pass thing yeah
but okay so just to to give a sense of
what we could do here i mean we could
have i mean you could even conceptualize
it another way you could conceptualize
it but this is not how you'd want to do
it is that you know the map has a call
to block
and it's just setting this this you know
the symbol it's like evaluation context
or something that's not the right name
and and uh you know as some association
or something or even with down values
i don't know if that's available syntax
is that available syntax
it's extremely obscure
it is fun
but we have to this thing would have to
have a name so this is called
you know this is if it's like
environment variable it's a it's a um
uh
you know it's what we were talking about
before it's an ambient value or
something
context is obviously taken but otherwise
something like that would be could work
i don't think that's that
uh i'm not sure if the val i mean in
both these cases not just the value adds
anything other than i don't know
obscure
yes well i think it's that that's one of
its objectives is to sound less obscure
so is this an alternative to supplied
because i don't see how you would use
this in the symbols of definitions case
i think this is all i think this is not
what do you mean the symbol definitely
yes
i want to define a
i think and then put that in my code how
do i use this feature with that
i think this would make that unnecessary
right well well i don't know i mean
there's there's still the useful case i
mean i think that's
the case the what is it the two argument
case of supplied where you just give it
a string in the first argument that is
still something that i think is not
why is that useful i don't understand
why that's useful why are you not just
why is it useful to have the symbol
power in the language
no no no instead of having a huge pure
function every time you want to do a
power no no you're being silly look at
this thing that's what i'm saying i will
want to write code where i use f i'm
just asking how to use
this feature with that at all i don't
see i don't know
a bad answer to that question is that
you could say f equals function of blah
blah blah no no no no why i don't
understand why is there a problem here
this thing here you'd be able to say
things like well whatever this thing is
um
you know that will be what it would look
like
and it would just you just say
but so you your solution is to exactly
not do the thing that i'm asking to do
what what are you trying to do what do
you want to do i don't want to use a
pure function i want to have a function
f that i just define down values or
whatever kinds of definitions for
i think the point is that you just
define it to have two arguments one of
them is the value of them is the index
and then when you want to map with it
you know the point is that you're gonna
have to special pattern matching no you
don't no no no you're not gonna do that
you're not gonna do it the fact is if
you're going to use okay so the one case
that you're not gonna get
is the case that map index does right
now where you mysteriously can say map
indexed of f comma whatever and you
happen to know that the second argument
to f that's supplied to f
is the you know position list
right you will not get that case you
would have to instead of that you would
have to explicitly say
i want to get the index list put into
the second argument of f
but i don't think that's bad because so
if i defined f separately then i would
also have to use the three argument form
of function potentially to have a pure
function with the same attributes as f
what i mean the thing is look look like
there's not a supplied case in a
supplied case said my point was silly
but it's the point that i'm making which
is you want to define symbols
no right right but i don't i don't think
there's anything i think
the the symbol you define is totally
analogous in this case that it would be
in a supplied case right so there's two
cases with supplied one is you just do
one is you do sort of a single argument
applied and it feeds the whole
association to your function
right
the other case is
you you give it uh
right and then the other cases you give
it certain like curated arguments if you
say supplied of i want the element i
want the index etc it the second case
the way you'd write that here is you
just write map of f of you know
hash
you know hash
index
not hash index but you do you know hash
funky symbol index funky symbol position
etc i mean it's the same thing it's just
instead of putting the list in the first
argument supplied you put it into these
arguments there
no it really isn't
because because first of all you've lost
the attributes of f by putting it in a
pure function
um
and the second is right you were talking
about
we right we could directly substitute
things in and not have the
you know
not not have sort of the pure function
there and i think we've lost that
right because you you have to go now
through the pure function
it'll have to stay
in fact i'm not entirely sure how this
is no it does not happen
i'm not sure in fact even how this would
work
no no this does not require any pure
function at all
this is just
it just substitutes it looks like
some values
and down values
so this would require you to define f
using sub values
in this particular case yes
so that's what i'm saying like that
just a simple question how do i use down
values with this i don't see the answer
oh you have to i'm sorry i don't totally
understand other than maybe the
attributes case yeah which which i which
i argue is kind of niche i mean it's not
super common that you you know i i
rarely even set attributes for down
values that you know for random little
internal functions
and and so i mean maybe other people do
but
you know assuming you don't have
attributes it's just map of it's just
map of and then the arguments i'm saying
that at the point that you're
at the point that you've chosen to
define a function and call it f you want
to then write code that has f in it and
not have to staple a bunch of
boilerplate to it or wrap it in a pure
function
but see what that pure function is
providing the point is okay one of the
questions is at what point do you
specify hey i'd like to get the index or
i'd like to get the position or i'd like
to get whatever field and i think one
option is that you you you ask for that
inside of f and the other option is that
you ask for that you know outside of the
f but somehow inside of the map
and i would argue that that asking for
the index for the first time inside of
an f defined with down values
is is kind of i i think that's that
would be bad code if nothing else
because it just means that the function
is sort of mysteriously tied in in some
ways that you can only use it inside of
map which i will do
i'm going to want to write a function
i'm going to write lots of functions
that can only ever be called from within
a supplied of a certain type
right
they have an argument that's going to
that they expect to be in association
with certain keys right well it expects
to be a sequence of arguments
yes
right but you've look your function has
three arguments let's say you expect the
second one to be an index
okay
but you could you know you you could
call your function in a test or
something
with just a three as the second argument
you didn't have to come from a named
thing called index
and what we're arguing about is whether
what you do
is to say is to just put the f there
whether you're specifying what the
arguments should be by having explicit
supplied wrapped around it whether
you're specifying the arguments by
building a pure function here and having
this go this way and you're arguing
correctly but i think it's a you know
that the case of attributes is not well
handled here
right in this case
it's also just not the case that when
you define a function you then expect to
every time you use that function to be
using it as a
as but no no no no no it's just that it
expects i i don't think it's just that f
expects certain arguments you know
expects the index for example right for
example if i wrote a function
maybe you just write if it's if it's
power it doesn't expect the index it's
just you've decided to feed it the index
right right so you can specify that
you're feeding at the index either this
way
or this way
wait i i
i mean and
okay in your
we're just saying the question of
whether this is the primary way of doing
it whether we provide this way as well
is something of a detail as far as i'm
concerned we shouldn't kill this way of
doing it just because we're going for
this way of doing it well yeah so i
guess the question is just let's not
kill the second way
i i'm not necessarily the first one
and if that's all if that is happens
then i have no objections to both of
these rights but i mean this way we
don't have to do the lexical scanning of
supplied we have a different mechanism
which is more general we have to do the
lexical scanning of every single one no
i i know that i know that i know that
so we haven't actually in fact we're
doing more work rather than less
okay
i think we can solve that problem
yeah i mean maybe there might be some
obscure way of doing it with uh
you know some sort of down values or
something i i don't know i think that
i'm not
we have all kinds of ways to do it
for um
but sorry i mean the thing the thing i'm
arguing is just that these are these are
very equivalent things i mean these are
almost just different syntax yes well
too big no well to be clear the first
one is a strict subset of the second one
i don't see what that like i think it's
the example
it is not it is not it is not consider
the rule case
no no not even with the rule case i mean
i i don't understand what the
i don't understand the use case where
you could i i just think these are
basically just different syntax i don't
understand the use case where you could
use supplied and you couldn't use this
even with attributes and because supply
is just again applying the function with
certain arguments which is exactly what
you're doing here
where you're putting in where you have a
hold or something and you're it's the
difference between your function
wrapping is
an expression yes we understand
you mean if f is hold on
and you say
right i just mean the first one is pure
functions and the second one is
arbitrary expressions therefore the
first one is a strict
subset of the second one
except that the first one you can use
you can use this mechanism in rules and
other places where you cannot use this
mechanism
because i mean it seems like we would
need if
if we want to do rules then i think we
definitely need something like the first
one the question is just whether or not
we want to extend that to also be the
thing for function yeah i i think the
first one makes sense in the body of a
pure function and on the right hand side
of rules
right i have no i i i i mean it seems
like i said it's like i have no
mechanism
given that we're going to try and get
people to understand this mechanism that
first mechanism seems very easy to
understand
you know what this is analogous to it's
analogous to the function stack
is it not i mean if i say map f of
hash comma stack i mean just in the
sense that it's a it's a it's a symbol
that you know it's a function that gives
you information about the context in
which the function is applied
right
um
let's say this is a mapple
did i make a mistake here
is does f have attributes or something
now actually here's the problem i i need
to say something like plus
i guess this is correct yeah i guess
this is correct this is a stack
but that's just for the sake of oh oh
yeah the
yes
entertainingly obscure
but correct
right and you see as it comes out
the stack is less
deep
right and then that's why i was saying
that maybe there'd be some way
yeah maybe there'd be some efficient way
of implementing this with just down
values of some kind
right but the point that we're making
here is while this particular thing that
we just did is not very useful
semantically it's the same type of thing
that we're asking for
correct
yeah
and although stack
which is kind of interesting is global
to the rebel
right this isn't it isn't delimited it's
scope
its evaluation scope is not delimited by
the map all
right the stack is referring maybe this
things wouldn't be either it's just that
it would have more stuff that could tell
you inside of matt ball yeah well quite
i mean that's an interesting possibility
that it has some questions it could ask
that go all the way up to the rep
i mean one concern would be yeah one one
concern would be just that
uh i know functions like stack sometimes
introduce sort of bizarre edge cases
where it's like you know uh
right you're writing some piece of code
and you expect that oh i'm just applying
this function but actually the function
can look up into you know into your code
and do weird stuff and you know
like
right
but i do like the idea that that this
thing which you know
we can
is essentially a situational
you know it's an environment variable
it's a it's a well it's a situational i
don't know what the right name for it is
thing that has
you know that's basically telling you
about the evaluation state
um
all right well uh okay i think we've had
tom here to talk about auto completes
but actually the way that the semantics
is developing i don't think we need the
auto completes that we were thinking
about before because what we were
thinking about was an autocomplete that
depends on the fact that it's inside of
supplied here but i don't think we i
don't think we need that
but based on what we're now saying
okay i don't know
can i ask how to complete it's going to
be harder right or easier depending on
how you look at it
the autocomplete is going to if it is
based on a funky symbol there's a oh i
see what you're saying yes the
autocomplete is going to depend on what
the outer function wrapping that was
whether it's a map or a cases or
something else
yeah also i think we need to think a bit
more about the implementation of this
thing and so on before we can yeah i
know we're we're not ready for the audit
i was just checking that the
um
before we go on can i can i just ask
like as a summary of what we just
discussed so you'd have the funky symbol
that you would use in a pure function
and you wouldn't have to wrap the pure
function in anything you just use the
pure function yeah and have the funky
symbol
yeah the [ __ ] also use funky symbol
on the right hand side of a rule exactly
and the funky symbol could supply just
be the two argument thing and it doesn't
do the lexical scanning because yeah i
think that's what
what funky symbols job is
[Music]
that you were proposing as the possible
symbol
i'm sorry what are you saying what
uh for for the the syntax is that out at
bang
you know add sign exclamation that's
what i typed yes
okay
uh that bang seems like a pseudo-random
solution
okay okay
i'm just thinking about it i mean
but by the way if we think of this thing
as sort of like the quote-unquote
environment variable
way where it's basically just that as
map goes conceptually i'm not sure
that's how it actually worked
conceptually it's just that as map goes
you know every iteration it will define
environment variable of quotes index
equals you know whatever the new index
is and so on if that's how it worked
then if you did have a down value
function f
you could just reference this thing in
that function and as long as the map is
still happening it's like block that
will be that variable that's except you
don't know that i'm not sure that's good
code i'm not sure yeah i'm not sure it
has to it has to be um
i mean if we hadn't
if we hadn't defined
okay here's an outrageous
suggestion which probably won't work
okay just like
if you use a capital letter variable
name
in your code
eventually over the course of time the
function that you use the named of the
capital letter could get overtaken right
if you if you'd said subset replace you
had a function called subset replace
inversion 12 point whatever that got
overtaken by our system subset replace
crazy suggestion
what if we use dollar sign
and and a capital letter and
these simply are the dollar index
set
you know dynamically inside whatever it
is
is that completely crazy
and i mean dollar index
if you normally used it would just say
sorry i don't know what the value is the
missing not available or whatever it is
instead of funky symbol of string index
yeah
that we just define a new symbol
that
is we would have here that there um
right so this is this is this is the you
know in the same way that you could do
funky symbols quotes index map could
just run you know conceptually different
quotes index it could instead just run
dollar index equals blah blah blah
here's what it would say if you want to
do map index you would simply say this
as long as it's still okay that these
symbols have different interpretations
and different functions
yes i mean it's just like you can look i
mean i think the interpretation
it's not even interpreted it's just that
the function map as it runs is at least
conceptually maybe actually
you know redefining this symbol and and
it's just documented that hey map map
redefines index in this way and do in
default redefines index in this other
way and you know and so on
yeah i mean there's a bit of a weird
scoping thing of what if i mean like
what is the context of that symbol and
so anything that's a dollar
system
anything that's dollar initial cap is
now in system even if it's completely
meaningless wait no no no no no
no no no no no
yeah this is and
the actual assignment could work very
much like what table does for its local
variables
um
oh so so oh there is a scoping question
you're proposing that we define you know
a finite list of like 12
variables yeah
okay sorry i i thought
well you know what what i misunderstood
so yeah i mean it might be lots
might be quite a few and there are a few
here i mean where we would you know
these parametrized ones like results are
and we probably we might not get those
or we might have a i mean this is this
is a new family of variables i mean what
are some other examples of things like
this that get dynamically set
dollar random state does it get
dynamically set sorry one other question
is what's the scoping if i have a map in
a map if there's some way of getting the
outer one
i say no
okay
so if you want the outer one when you do
the inner map you should pass in the
current value of dollar index yeah i
mean it's like saying can you get the
outer hash sign in you know the outer
slot and the answer is no
the only way to get or the outer x when
you have two things called x nested
within each other and then the way to do
that is just to add another argument to
your inner function and then pass in x
so it's dollar right um
i was going to say uh in answer to your
question it's dollar random generator
state and yes that is
you know the current value of the
randomness generator whatever
that happens to be so right so it you
know it effectively has a little down
value that its own value is essentially
a little bit of down code that says
what's the current generator state
right
now this could work the same kind of way
i don't know it depends on how what it's
picking itself stuff up from but this is
i mean this is certainly a clean way to
do this i think and it's a way where the
code will not look particularly obscure
i mean if somebody types you know that
piece of code is not
obviously is not terribly obscure
right and i like the fact that it has
dollar in it so since we're thinking of
this as quote unquote environment
variables the fact that it has dollar
you know i know i know
um
possible
is if i
if i define a function
with a down value
you know say f of x you know underscore
colon equals
you know dollar index
plus x
and i then do map of f
um you know with with usual scoping
rules that would
that would quote work it would it would
you know set set a value of index and
then evaluate f and that would be
evaluated or we thinking of something
totally lexical here
i'm not sure i always think it'd be more
of a block situation
right the problem there is which which
which which you know that's totally
flexible and amazing and nice problem
there is that then
we have to set all of these variables
every every instance yeah which we don't
want to have to do which we don't want
to have to do so i think i think we have
to i mean as lovely as i think that
would be we have to keep it a lexical
thing
yeah okay fine fine you know ethanol
livestream is saying don't use dollar
sign everybody uses that for global
variables and it's true people do use it
for global variables on the other hand
you know
well we have a limited on the other hand
they shouldn't use it with dollar sign
capital variable names but i'm sure they
do
i'm sure they do just like people use i
mean you know and occasionally i mean
i've found it's kind of amusing a bunch
of code from the early 90s that we're
wheeling out again for the nks book 20th
anniversary thing you know it works just
fine except there are functions defined
there that have now become built-in
functions because they were used with
capital letters and so on
um and that's you know that if that's
the price of progress it's not the worst
thing in the world and i i don't think i
don't think we have a lot of other
characters that we can use here i mean
we can think about it but i mean what
other valid symbol names do we have
because that's what we want here so we
want something which is either well it
could be an operator but i think it's
much nicer for it just to be a symbol
name because among other things that we
get to document this you know dollar
index is
the locally defined index in these
functions
right well i mean if if we wanted to try
to minimize breaking code we could do
dollar dollar index which is unlikely to
be
yes i understand
i mean by the time people are using
dollar dollar i we
we can we can review this yeah right and
that
and i suppose one argument in favor of
double dollars that that sort of
suggests that it's something other
different from your normal global
variables
and it's not very hard to type and it's
not very ugly
it reminds me deeply of snp but that's a
different matter
it had a use for those things anyway
never mind that
its use wasn't very good
um
that's not terrible
i mean i agree that that saves the
obscurity of global variables
because we haven't used dollar dollar
for anything right
not anything in system context
no we use it sometimes for internal
things but in more or less this way
right
well i agree that that's not that's not
terrible
and it's not as obscure as i thought it
was going to be
i mean i'm used to it being obscure
because we use it obscurely in our
internal code
i like this
let's inventory what it would take and
let's understand the implementation here
and that's inventory what symbols we
would actually want
and um
here we go from that we have run out of
time
so uh
yeah this is an important thing all
right
we should wrap up here